blow take it alert gang get your tickets
to The Gramercy theater and come out and
see the boys February 3rd yeah gang it's
our third show we added the Army garbage
came out strong sold out the first two
we added a third let's sell this last
one out we love yous let's do it welcome
so another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that at
the group to be classy yeah or if
they're just a big old piece of trash
I'm your host Tate trolley coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here at
antuti's basement she's upstairs
flipping pigeons okay cops are coming
all right whatever my co-host is coming
at you right next to me he is the CEO of
are you garbage all the guys on Main
Street kiss his ass and all the boys on
Wall Street are Running Scared give it
up for KJ Kevin James Ryan everybody oh
man I like that one that one's all right
what's up gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate if you
subscribe on iTunes oh yeah full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are
good and then obviously the greatest
goddamn website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage check it
the [ __ ] out gang we got a lot going on
over there episodes of
uh are you garbage we got bonus episodes
uh hard feelings we got a whole [ __ ] ton
of on a row we got a whole nother series
of Vlog of on the road us all over the
goddamn country and we just announced
our new goal you know what that is big
man uh Indianapolis 500 Indy 500.
passes we're going it's gonna be a good
time get involved gang yeah
yeah see it gang having a nice quick
shout out to our producer X Jordan Air
the magic man makes us all look good
works those ones Works those twos
crosses the t's dots the eyes does it
all with a magic marker give it up for
T-Bone mcgruffins it's Toby McMullen
everybody what's up dude what's good got
the giggles
check the pipes there's a leak in here
what am I gonna do that was funny we're
having a good time having a good time a
couple of friends few laughs we got Nate
Mack the human puppet
this guy's an easy leg you're welcome
back anytime there Nate man what if it's
again one of us is getting late after
this I felt bad to laugh because I was
like I haven't even introduced yet so I
sound like a crazy person and he's
looking at me like what the [ __ ] is he
doing but it's funny we're having a good
time what do you want man come on he's
got the Mad Hatter his eyes were
literally like I'm gonna cut his [ __ ]
mind right now dump it dump it don't be
silly gang we couldn't be more excited
to have one of our best Pals in a whole
wide world back with us today you know
him you love him he has a brand new
special out on his YouTube page right
now called money never wakes do us a
favor give it up for the one the only Mr
Nathan Macintosh
a little Canadian camo on I like to see
it you look like Jim Carrey and Dumb and
Dumber
100 people are boots man
oh man I like it I
like to obey I look like I robbed a gas
station in Colorado
put the money in a bag
you know what this isn't as funny as it
was earlier uh I do no I do but I like
it it's good it's it's
cool let's see what are you working with
it's a it's a movement watch it's just
it's just it's just a gold watch Adidas
yeah it's Adidas while I like Adidas
it's it's a plain old man
you got a soccer gold watch Dude Perfect
what's the problem with this is that a
stretchy band no come on man one of my
nine I don't know I left my [ __ ]
tricycle outside no it doesn't it's a
it's a real band it goes with a Skechers
chain
is this done by four I got a math class
to get to I don't I gotta pick up my
jankos from the dry cleaner and Adidas
watch what are you doing what do you
mean what do you want you're an Adidas
man I'm an Adidas man are you yeah I
didn't know that about you uh you never
asked fully yeah yeah you know it's only
you really walk up to people every once
in a while be like Nike Adidas we don't
Reebok walk away Puma the brother of uh
Dr Adidas Reebok I used to work at yeah
Adidas owns Reebok I believe I used to
work at Adidas I got into the stuff you
know what I mean
I said I worked at Adidas I mean if
somebody wants to take that on it's like
I was the [ __ ] you got to say I
worked at an Adidas not I worked at
Adidas he worked at Adidas four Adidas
thank you sure work at Adidas means
you're at the corporate headquarters God
damn it all right so I worked I worked
four Adidas okay in the very front
office
selling on the uh you know I was built
on the pavement you're a corner guy for
Adidas I like it I worked in the in the
in the shoe what are they called the
shoe deck at the uh the Adidas store
young and Dundas in Toronto and uh yeah
I did I I worked there retail that's the
front lines is tough yeah what years are
we talking here what years yeah I mean I
got a shift
[Laughter]
um
yeah my manager put this on me he's like
look at them as soon as it clicks 10 get
the walk back in the store did you get
that for your retirement is that what I
gave you the gold watch
I did two years at the mall
what are you gonna do now Nate I don't
know a little fishing yeah a little fish
in I might head up to Montauk I uh what
years did I work there I don't know two
I moved here in like 2011 so it was
right before that 2000 2010. the Kobe
years
yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay but it's more so they got a huge uh
soccer Department upstairs a lot of
[ __ ] soccer stuff I don't know
anything about soccer but some soccer
players came in and people like losing
their [ __ ] yeah yeah lines and I'm
just like who is that guy women are
crying guys are throwing their babies at
this dude soccer players are you know
I've seen it on uh Houston Street there
was an idea or something there was some
sort of whatever like the Nike stores
down there yeah it wasn't the Nike
though it might have might have been
Adidas or something and it was
full-blown crazy that somebody might
show up like he was in the city and
they're like he's sponsored by them he
might show up and it was like the block
was flooded they're dreamy those socks
that was in hockey Stars I like could
have been Dog the Bounty Hunter
we gotta get off the ice bruh Beth at
the time was big rest in peace I believe
right we're all a big rest in peace yeah
can I say we're talking well whatever
just as a side note I might maybe I said
this before have I said that have we
when I was my first time don't think so
did we uh well I'm here just like Adidas
dude
let me check the back
there was so many were you good with the
the finger did you test the the front no
you're not no that's not no my mom used
to get in there that's your mom I'm an
adult man who's being paid for the
building I'm not like putting a guy's
foot in it you don't even believe it you
got a little a lot of room in the crotch
there buddy
they don't really go with the shoes no
but people did come in and people don't
know their own shoe size like a people
would come in giant men you know feet
decides this table and they'd be like I
need a seven you go there's no way
they're like you're going on your
fingers it ain't gonna work size seven
in other shoes all right man you go
downstairs get a [ __ ] 16 come carry
it over your head like pour Tasha up the
stairs
um but well whatever Beth I'm moving on
I forgot if we even talked about it
before but uh I want to ask you this I
was thinking about this hold on he was
trying to get the best oh you were you
got a Beth go oh I'd thrown it away but
all I was gonna say is at the time oh I
think have I said this on like
when Dog the Bounty Hunter was out I uh
I had a huge crush on Beth whoa and his
wife I get that she's oh she's a she's a
what's the word voluptuous voluptuous
but like
takes the [ __ ]
[ __ ] she left your dick she let the
girls hang out too she was her she
wasn't walking she wasn't walking around
like Diane Keaton wearing turtlenecks
yeah no offense to it but I mean she
couldn't there wasn't you couldn't hide
those if you had a [ __ ] tar she'd
have to be in a straight jacket dude
absolutely even in a straight jacket
they'd have to have a hole in the front
and they go you know you're you we can't
lock these up I know I know but just the
nail like the gaudy [ __ ] Nails the
big hair the the fingerless leather
gloves American flag tank top yeah she
was all right now I'm chubbing up over
here by the way hey who doesn't like a
girl with a little bear spray on her you
know what I mean
that's what I'm talking yeah she would
like get in the mix too she'd like be
you know she'd snatch you up real quick
yeah yeah yeah she was all right
I have a whole uh she had a lot of gold
she had gold she wore gold too I believe
I think she had like a gold necklace
Goldie all Adidas that was all pawn shop
gold I'm sure totally yeah I was all
that was all repo gold you like the
gaudiness and abroad I I there's a part
of me that really does it's called the
Trashy Side of course it's you don't
want it because you know it's going to
be a problem but like you do know it's
good if a girl's got her name in her
earrings it's gonna be a problem shout
out to most of my cousins by the way I
can't wait stop Erica we love you I
can't wait till I'm digging one of her
nails out of my forehead I bet there's a
part of that that's so hot but also
you're gonna fight with that [ __ ]
lady in a goddamn Applebee's pick up a
bun and whip it in your eyes you know
yeah it's going down in public for sure
but a tanned a tanned that's the best
[ __ ] woman that's all like just the
hey get you going yeah yeah
become like an 80 year old man who's
who's uh like you know those gun like
the the billionaires or whatever that
end up just running around with women
exactly like that and all their money
goes to them
hey I don't hate it my third wife I
think that's what I'm gonna do yeah yeah
go real trashy there you go woman that
hits you it takes your cane at the pool
you limp dick [ __ ] not limp dick
anymore you got to take her second that
you got to take her and her boyfriend
out to dinner
she calls him her trainer yeah yeah I
was gonna ask soccer players are way
more famous worldwide than NBA or
football stars they are right of course
like who's more famous around the world
LeBron James or Messi Messi right time's
a I don't know though I was thinking
LeBron's really in there that's tough
LeBron is the exception but soccer
players I mean God are famous in [ __ ]
places where people don't have shoes and
you don't even have like don't even know
what basketball is yeah you know we were
talking about this one night actually
somebody was like who do you think it's
hotter women soccer players or
basketball players I go soccer yeah
there's just no because you're talking
about the universe you're talking about
and you also have a lot of those
countries that are like known for really
hot women yeah
Brazil you see that Miss Croatia that's
running around
she got famous at the World Cup Miss
Croatia for letting the girls hang out
in the stand I didn't see this and then
she's like hanging out with Drake it
wasn't babysitting either yeah
he ain't talking about some
nine-year-old yeah no a lot of you have
a lot of those you know untapped markets
for the NBA hockey players too they do
all right yeah hockey players there's a
rugged uh handsomeness about a hockey
player oh yeah yeah growing up in uh
growing up in Canada Nova Scotia all
those dudes all the guys that were like
plaid and they had like a [ __ ] jaw
lines in the hair every woman wanted to
[ __ ] those guys yeah whether they look
like a hockey not a hard-working guy at
the Adidas store no they never wanted me
he's a sunburned [ __ ] shoe Pusher
sunburnt at night let me guess you're a
seven and a half
people like uh yeah people like a
goddamn ethic but those guys uh even
when I go home now man you see you see
uh yeah women just with like they love
those [ __ ] hockey players but like
Dak Prescott or like Joe burrow because
they could go around Europe and probably
not get nobody might not know who they
are press guys
the quarterback uh Cowboys okay yeah I
know nothing but football yeah see he
can't he can't even go to Nova Scotia I
know a lot of people don't even go to
Nate's apartment yeah they can't even
come down these stairs I don't know the
[ __ ] who is that get that guy out of
here hey get your own sneakers I'm going
on break
take long breaks at y'all well you guys
you guys work retail I worked retail
most of my you know I was grocery store
uh Macy's yeah that was probably about
10 years grocery store in Macy's between
those two I I worked at a grocery store
but I also worked at um I worked at uh
Future Shop in uh what's that in Canada
future he told us about this it's like a
Best Buy yes but I used to go I used to
take like long long long long [ __ ]
lunches like huge huge breaks like two
and a half three hours grocery store I
used to steal [ __ ] rotisserie chicken
the superstore shout out to Naruto man
if the superstars like I love just
talking about places I've actually been
the um plus you paint a picture for
something generic names the superstore
in Bear Lake
right next to funny town
on the road to Main Street you guys know
what I'm talking about how come no we
don't got it folks yeah
I know if I if I well whatever so I used
to go I used to go I used to push carts
there and I was a cart man myself there
Nate yeah 78 to 81. yeah really you were
part guys that's ready to start yeah but
I was listening too I was I was 15 and I
was I had to look over the cards like
look at this I was just tiny little baby
man but I used to take on my lunch
breaks I would just take a full
rotisserie chick the whole chicken up to
the break room cracked the top you know
what you would steal and then sit there
that is kind of in plain sight type
stuff yeah but they don't know the
people that come up don't know that I
didn't pay for it also I'm 15. fire me I
I don't care I'll walk in here right now
give a [ __ ] I don't yeah I need fifty
dollars a year and 15. to have a gram
halfway there man you know what I mean I
used to make I sell this Roto I'm
sitting pretty for the week I made 50 a
week there and every time me and my
friend would get paid we would play For
the Love of Money OJ's and just be like
we have all of like we're getting a cold
45 going to a movie buying a bag of
party mix still got 30
[Laughter]
who's fighting Colt 45s at 15. you got
you guys are Looney Tunes up there how's
the divorce going buddy
Colt 45 in a rotisserie chicken yikes
yeah 25 and chicken in a bag maybe
that's all I need is that a song got a
food truck a futon to sleep on and a a
gutter to drink from well you want a
futon no no no you guys had your own
rooms right you and your you and your
bro when we were kids no when we when we
were kids we didn't we had bunk beds my
brother would kick the [ __ ] um to
piss me off the bottom he I was on the
top he's on I'm the older brother he'd
kicked the [ __ ] bottom of my bed
until I would come down and like fight
him that wasn't one of those cool bunk
beds where it was a big bed at the
bottom and a small one at the top those
dropped in the 90s did they go did it go
on an angle was it perpendicular to each
other those were sweet no no no not the
number of those yeah they only do they
only exist in a magazine the one that
went this way then the one that went
that way yeah no way they had a ladder
and like a slide and all that stuff that
was in like the movie blank check shout
out to blank Preston Waters bought that
with his million dollars no this was a
regular ass two bed stacked on top of
each other [ __ ] little ladder that
you barely even used stepped on the top
threw yourself up yeah but my brother
used to kick the bottom of it and uh so
you know we shared we had we shared a
room the whole time all through high
school too we look man I come from real
garbage I moved out of my house when I
was 16. so uh no no yeah man I did I
lived in a guys what are we doing here
so I'm sure we've talked about that no I
didn't know you moved out at 16. yeah I
I well I moved what I thought that's
middle aging that's run away technically
you ran away there's a whole other store
that we don't even need to get into this
is a fun podcast we don't bring this
down yeah I don't want to talk about my
circus years
which would have been at the Halifax the
um no so I ended up uh going to live
with my friend to to finish out high
school and I was like uh his family or
yeah his mom really because my mom my
mom was moving to uh mayor machine New
Brunswick look I'm gonna keep saying all
of the the names sure yeah because
whatever but so she was going up there
and I wanted to finish High School in
Halifax
um so my friend was like hey Mom can
[ __ ] Nathan live with us and she's
like yeah so I ended up living with my
friend for the last year and I he dude
he made me a bed out of a futon this is
ridiculous this is what the show is how
the hell did we get it how the hell we
went from Beth's man Gorgeous Hair he's
a guarded boy
sleeping in a straw manger my friend
made a [ __ ] uh there's a real reason
I did a whole special talking about
money my my friend made a broke a bed
for me out of a broken futon on some
milk crates whoa and he took and he took
the closet doors off of his closet so my
head was it in the closet yeah my head
was in the closet under shirts so if I
woke up there was shirts on my head and
I was I was in a bed I was on a futon
bed broken on some [ __ ] milk crates
that was my last year of high school
that's a good friend though man he
really wanted you to stay there yes and
I'll say this man we had um so I I'm I
had an older brother he was two years
older all of his friends were all really
cool I love you know I idolized him and
all that stuff and for a while one of
his boys uh he had trouble at the house
and he stayed with us for like two
months man that was a [ __ ] sleepover
oh dude yeah man it really it really was
a good time it was me my friend uh
Andrew ham who's a [ __ ] great cartoon
shout out to Andrew yeah a ham and Day
on on Instagram but he he um it was me
him and his brother and uh it was
[ __ ] great man like legitimately that
time was awesome his mom's crazy but in
the best possible way she would yell at
us all the time about random [ __ ]
you know what I mean because we come in
high as [ __ ] sometimes and his mom was
sleeping in a closet you got to think
the edge off wake up in a head fully
shirts and trousers
you just hit me in the head with a denim
[ __ ] shirt cut my face but uh no it
really was it really was a great time I
imagine every shirt in the closet is
denim yeah yeah it's Canada it's denim
hockey jersey CCM stick
shout out to CCM make a hell of a
product that was more of a bower man
myself some uh there was some uh hockey
skates you know what I mean just
swinging over my head the whole time
just hoping the knot was done right
but it is funny about like you think
about the like times like that where
like just but then and then you grow up
and you gotta pay tax and you're like
you know what man sleep in the closet
wasn't so yeah it wasn't so bad man wait
it's so bad I don't know microwave ain't
too bad sometimes yeah yeah it's one of
those things where like you don't know
you had about six problems then right
one of them was that you were sleeping
in a closet can I if I'm being real
serious it wasn't even a problem I know
yeah there's no pressure having a
[ __ ] ball I just started comedy I was
finishing high school and you did 55 I
bought a comedy in high school yeah well
right after high school I started
calling I was 19. I'm a crazy person did
you didn't go to college did you no I
went to I went to Humber College in uh
in Toronto so bumper Humber yeah okay go
ahead Ron's a lumber it was uh so I was
I was riding these logs right down a
river
um Humber Humber Humber had this [ __ ]
I mean this is real hobo Humber has a
comedy program okay
I have a two-year comedy program right I
went solely so I could get to Toronto I
was like how the [ __ ] am I going to get
to try I'm living in a closet how do you
go from Nova Scotia to Toronto how many
miles is 15 hey whatever 18 or 17 year
old that is oh so I understand of like
how I can get x amount of Miles yeah to
this place with this that's crazy once a
month in Nova Scotia there's two moose
that leave and they and they had one too
only one comes back I missed I missed
the last moves around the town so I went
to I went to Humber College for one year
and then I I dropped out and just kept
doing comedy just stayed in Toronto nice
intro Humber College has a 70 acceptance
rate nice well comedy buddy who's not
taking I want to give you money to do
comedy like get in your sucker I mean
what are you talking about of course
they do here's your Blazer and roll the
sleeves up you don't mind sleeping in a
closet do you I prefer it sir
yeah I can assume they have a [ __ ]
high but anyways so I did I didn't did
you know what short answer no I didn't
go to college
I went to a clown school there was
literally a clown class there was a
clown class a sketch class a stand-up
class that is
hold on it's like you took a clown class
yeah did you ever do your makeup they
didn't do we didn't do makeup this is uh
dropped out the first year they were the
second year I was a third semester we
got into the red noses third year is the
Professor comes over and just slaps the
lipstick out of your hand honks while he
does it
no then give me your oversized shoes
what's that movie they're not made for
it what's the movie about the drumming
squeeze itself
a flower Drumline
Drumline oh you're drama Whiplash yeah
Drumline is the drum move yeah I guess
Whiplash came in that Jack Cannon and
Drumline JK yeah that movie's great okay
let's talk about that indochino Indo
Chino best in the best let's talk about
not looking like a bozo for 2023. oh
yeah come correct baby I'm getting on
that they got custom made gear over
there you get Blazers you get suits
tuxedos the whole nine yards gang you
don't need a tailor you [ __ ] take
care of it easy peasy let's go yeah you
get to start getting laid you get to
choose every detail in the suit the
shirt the dinner jacket and more like a
nice dinner jacket inner jacket uh fully
custom pieces the affordable prices may
surprise you uh I've used indochino
before you I got it for a wedding not
too long ago you come in looking real
tight fresh crisp everything's made the
order baby all right that's what they
can do for the big boys made to the
exact measurements because I'm not a guy
who can walk in and grab one off the
rack and walk out no I need a suit I
need the Jacket's got to be 10 times
bigger than the pants it's gonna be real
short looking like a fat kid at a
wedding oh it's a tough law create a
suit to fit you and your style perfectly
they offer options for Fabrics lapel
shape custom Monograms 62-30 over here
upside down fractions the best part into
indochino Suits start at Just 4 49 and
shirts from 89 indochino all also offers
completely custom fitted shirts casual
wear and more get a wardrobe
personalized to your style and taste
without spending a fortune here you go
baby if you're ringing in 2023 with
Wedding Bells ahead start planning your
custom look with indochino go to
indochino.com use the code garbage get
10 off your purchase at 3.99 or more
baby go that's indochino
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o.com promo code garbage
now do it better help baby oh better
talk about it I'm a clientele calling
all the psychos and wackadus out there
cuckoo brains you got to someone at
better how we all are two of them
sitting right here gang life's coming
life comes at you fast yeah throws a
high heat that in city buses buddy I'm
not getting no intentional walks with
life over here I'm taking a high heat
down the middle so gang if you're
working through something better help
can't help do yourself a favor get on
there they match you with a licensed
therapist do it from the comfort and the
privacy of your own home and who don't
love a little privacy you know what I
mean I'd do a pant list shout out to
Cody I like to watch uh guys I signed up
it's awesome uh uh it it's five percent
less crazy
it's fantastic just talking to somebody
they have a messaging system it's easy
peas you can do live chats the whole
nine yards uh if you want to live a more
empowered life therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com garbage today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help help.com garbage one more
time get a pen get a pencil write it out
betterhelp help.com garbage today
that joke actually
die so we did do CL we did have it we
did a whole nose thing I've done wait
what's a whole nose thing you you put on
a clown nose and you do clown the guy
that taught it was like a clown like a
real clown not like a birthday clown not
like a circus clown like a clown clown
it wasn't just a jerk he was he was a
yeah
I don't know he was uh he was uh no
clown so we did clown one time nose
clown
wow yes we it's it was look man I wanted
to get to Toronto this is uh
yeah a small boy could get there we're
not judging you I'm just saying yeah wow
I'll tell you this the stand-up class
rode the whole way in the giraffe car on
the train first of all
your head's sticking out this man uh so
first of all I absolutely love this man
so but I'm going to tell this story
because whatever the guy that taught the
stand-up classes man
um Canadian comedian named Larry
Horowitz okay he taught a thing one time
and look I love Larry all right
this doesn't this isn't a but this is
one of the stand-up classes this is how
insane a comedy can get I I can't make
this up this man goes look man being on
the road in comedy is tough we're
talking years ago before you know what I
mean he goes speed on the road's tough
right so next class I'm gonna teach you
guys how to cook an egg on a lamp oh my
God and a lamp I laugh because I go well
that's hilarious that's not real yeah it
was real dude I left that class I was
like I'm not cooking I'll I'll spend the
six bucks McIntosh your eggs aren't
fluffy enough you're out
sloppy joes and a coffee maker like
horrific horrific that that's not
terrific [ __ ] what a pretty good idea
they had a cheat on your wife with a
waitress
not a close with some Road trim part two
how to make a ten dollar bill look like
a 20.
holy [ __ ]
hold it fold it just rice
oh my God how to sleep in the gym of a
Holiday Inn no it was really like like
folks I'm gonna teach you how to eat
maraschino cherries for dinner
that's all right I like the sloppy joe
one who has Coke in the audience
yeah man it was a real thing and it was
a real [ __ ] sadness like oh God I'm
I'm I'm skipping that whatever not doing
it um anyways but it got me Toronto when
I stayed in Toronto and did stand up for
years that's great I didn't know you
guys had sloppy joes up there I didn't
know it was that was internet that's
like a soccer player I'm actually called
Wacky Willies we call them meatball
coffee makers
wacky will you want some coffee pop slop
he wants a beef hat trick
um no we got sloppy joes I mean to what
do we call I think yeah we do [ __ ] me in
the gut show us how many how many ways
can you call that I love them they're my
favorite really oh sloppy joe where I
was from a Wilkes-Barre we called them
wimpies you're from wilkesbury
wilkesbury Pennsylvania I was born can I
ever tell you this [ __ ] story lay it
on me you know wilkesbury I know
Mountaintop
price how the [ __ ] did I not know this
until right this second I don't know
Wilkes-Barre is one of the craziest
things I've ever seen happen in my life
doing to talk about comedy I'm bombing
my bag all the way off okay bag is out
the door I'm on stage eating my dick
post died middle died I'm walking I'm
standing in the back oh he's there
eating a [ __ ] sloppy joe next
there was a guy in the crowd who's
massive huge
that's Mr Foley to you jack dude huh
yeah I ripped some guy who looked like
he literally was just fishing with his
[ __ ] feet Giant
mountain creature he's sitting in the
crowd he has a tiny little hat on like a
little like a like like like like like
this like a little hat and he audibly
farts
this had to be a Foley dude this had to
be like a third cousin or something it
might it might have been he audibly
farts crowd dies because this is
wilkesbury I look at him I go come on
man he goes
and then I just had to riff with this
guy for [ __ ] 20 minutes should be
hosting the stand-up class he should yes
you're trying to squeeze out a fart
I appreciate yourself for my closer yeah
if your material is not working class
how to violently [ __ ] yourself in front
of wood creatures I know you're from
wilkesbury that's crazy yeah now
watching the casino and trees yeah
there's a city there it used to be it
was very it was very prosperous back in
the day you had railroad you had
Trucking you had bottling it was uh salt
of the earth kind of town yeah I like
truckers and Jimmy Carter came in ruined
him
yeah my mama my mom ran over the Philly
Fanatic in Wilkes-Barre
[Laughter]
so there's uh there's a place in
wilkesbury called Public Square which is
uh just Public Schools
every day actually around the private
building every day I knew the man goes
in Forest to let you know it's noon
that's the bell tower yeah the smell
Tower
they have like a a fair every year or
something like that and you know every
once in a while you know you spend a
little money you get some [ __ ] big
shots in there and The Fanatic showed up
and he was doing a bit running across
the street and bankrupted the town
we had two choices hospital or fanatic
I mean come on I got good news and bad
news Fanatics coming everybody's gonna
have to suture their own cuts for the
rest of the year and ironically the
fnatic could have used the hospital
so your mom [ __ ] nailed the fanatic
as he's running across the street he was
doing a bit running it back and forth
running around and uh she she was
driving and didn't see him and he was he
like ran across the street and he jumped
on the hood and she hit him
and then he would put his little thing
out of his mouth and then got off almost
like you ever see the movie Thinner no
no it's uh it's a Stephen King movie but
a guy he hits a a gypsy and she puts a
curse on him but same sort of deal and
he keeps getting thinner yes he's he's a
big dude
I start Trucking some gypsies
just pulling into old women anyways
that's the whole thing that's what
reminds me of this [ __ ] uh your mom
nailing The Fanatic and then putting
having some curse put on her you know
she's always getting yelled at him
he'll keep growing and growing and
growing
he's gonna fart at a comedy show at a
casino
all right let's quit [ __ ] around
let's get into some cues here gang as
you know when you sign up for the old
patreon you can have a question right on
the air by Kevin James Ryan himself
hello he's no Philly fanatic I'll tell
you that
'll take a running your mom though
uh all right this one's from Kevin's
Soundbar uh very good name so it's a
very deep gun yeah
um
I'm not trying to make fun of this guy
at all it sounds like it sounds like a
music store yeah yeah Kevin sounds
pretty good Kevin Soundbar Toby got a
sound bar for Christmas last year we
hated them why I gave mine away I stunk
it was more of I just wasn't gonna set
mine up got you don't say nothing but I
don't oh hey buddy hey Diva I love a
sound bar good for you man you want one
I got one I got I got I guess I could
stack yours on top of mine double up
baby don't be sad
behind the couch remember that when you
started putting the speakers behind the
couch we never did that I didn't either
but you go to people's houses and the
wires running all over the [ __ ] place
dude that wire would come loose [ __ ]
yeah the little black one and a little
red one you stick it in there man the
home stereo set up for a while was
[ __ ] so trashy it was so wild none of
it worked it never worked so many chords
so many lights I hate when you when you
had those ones that like just lit up
even when they were off they would still
just like constantly light up hey look
aren't I cool it looks like a [ __ ]
pinball machine CD players spinning
around digitally yeah you say that now
until you walked into the future shop
and you're like you gotta get the lights
yeah listen buddy you know what your
living room needs lights that go off at
random I wouldn't mind a stereo system
to be honest with you there was
something comforting about it
I want a woofer so give me a woofer if
you don't got a woofer you're not
getting nothing on my high school
girlfriend
what are we doing
remember we have a good buddy and it
gets a little wacky you get a little
silly uh all right back to Kevin's
Soundbar first time long time
1450 homie because I'm Canadian trash
there we go shout out to the exchange
rate uh is it garbage can I I'm sorry to
cut yo what's going on with that why is
it why is it more into World Finance
yeah totally we're going to break it
down does the Dollar not hold up to the
Canadian uh the other way around the
Canadian dollar isn't as strong as the
US oh so they have to pay a little more
yeah all right
a second ago you're gonna go to war
what about the pound do we still stack
up with the British pound uh that's
probably they're all the pre the pound
the Euro and the dollar always very
close like one to one to one point one
or whatever because for a while I was
there was the first time I've been there
in eight years where the dollar
was Stronger so I had more purchasing
power yeah they were kicking the [ __ ]
out of us for a little while right
remember the European tourists had come
over and spend all our money yeah I went
years ago that's what they do get their
hands on some [ __ ] American yeah that
was I'm saying this when the when the
Euro was so much stronger than the
dollar yeah they'd come over here and
spend it you're talking about when the
Iron Curtain was up and they'd come over
and get Beatles tapes and blue jeans
they still smuggle them back really yeah
yeah Levi's are a big thing because they
can't get them everywhere over there
working at uh Adidas in the in the front
office it was mostly it was a lot of
[ __ ] Brazilians that were buying
shoes because apparently uh Adidas shoe
in in Brazil this is what I was told
anyways like 500 bucks oh really yeah
tough to get in yeah yeah they were just
stacking them up huh interesting we
should look into that what shipping
importing exporting a little bit yeah
what the [ __ ] we doing there's money
sitting out on the table big bag of
shoes drop it over Rio there you go guys
I have at it I hope you like Shaq shoes
uh all size five I got a cartel
submarine full of Yeezys
Coast Guard banging on the door
they're just kicks I swear
all right Kevin Soundbar is a garbage to
drink shots of soda from the ketchup
cups at McDonald's while waiting for
food because you didn't buy a drink
that's that's why does he say what part
of Canada uh no just Canadian trash he
says I really wonder what I'm gonna
guess Alberta but uh is that is that
like yours your South Alberta's like our
Texas okay and I I'm just guessing that
for fun I have no idea this man this man
I could have went to [ __ ] high school
with this guy could be the guy to let
you live in the closet real quick
actually one of your professors a clown
college
is it rude to honk your nose while
you're waiting for your nuggets the um
one time at uh in [ __ ] um and then
and and yes yes that is trash yes it is
but it's also I understood for you I do
too it's like I don't care what anybody
thinks that's a deeper commitment
anybody can walk into Chipotle and get
the water cup they act like they're
stealing the Mona Lisa nobody gives his
[ __ ]
that little phone by the way you gotta
let that settle remember the little
whack the little wax ones he's probably
talking about exactly yeah yeah yeah you
know what you had to do with those you
hold them out he thinks you mean open a
ketchup packet drain the ketchup out of
it rinse it fill it up drinking root
beer and have a mustard bottle
that is real trash but I do I like it
it's great I I respect the brazenness of
it of just like I don't I'm just [ __ ]
wetting my whistle over here nobody's
gonna get to McDonald's nobody gives a
[ __ ] there's a goddamn guy living in the
bathroom somebody somebody's jumped the
counter to beat somebody half to death
those videos are getting wild they would
love it if the only problem at
McDonald's is some guy [ __ ] putting
root beer in a goddamn ketchup thing
yeah my friend one time we were hungover
as hell in uh at a McDonald's and he
goes uh it was breakfast and he goes uh
he goes hey man look and he's trying to
show me like what he did with a [ __ ]
Egg McMuffin I don't even know but he's
so hungover both so [ __ ] up I look
down his balls are out his balls are
completely out of his shorts I go buddy
you're [ __ ] breakfast
[Laughter]
there's
craziness full-on breakfast hanging
brain was all right man you catch
somebody hanging out dude I'll never
forget I was probably nine my cousin was
12 13 and he goes he had like you know
basketball shorts on or something and he
hit me with ah [ __ ] I sat in some bubble
gum so I turned a look at this nuts
hanging out
first glance it looks like Bubba
the first time you saw those things
you're like God damn you saw like a
court you saw like a a more like a
mature ball bag when you were a kid that
was scary what the [ __ ] how is mine
gonna look like that a mature ball bag
I one time got uh supposedly one year
ban from I don't think the guy had the
the authority to really ban me from the
from the McDonald's in my town because
we were doing jello shots
and we wanted those ketchup cups right
yeah because they're perfect okay well
when I went to get I was just going to
steal them from there we needed like a
hundred or whatever and you can't this
was like you now you would just I'm sure
you could just order those on Amazon and
they'd be there the next day but this is
high school or whatever
even if you could do it in high school
you're not going to order them yeah it's
a way a better thing to steal them if
you can or yeah yeah yeah yeah Gonna
Mail away for cups for a party that's
real cool no one's coming to that party
I put on the Flyers stolen from local
McDonald's
all right I don't really get to put
traffic as they're cool
um we're you know weigh 100 a couple
hundred we needed we needed see that
Shelley that's a Wendy's napkin what's
up with grease stains on it already
every Wendy's napkin comes pre-standing
the [ __ ] Dirty Fingers going in there
it's just that darker shade of yellow
[ __ ] I'm supposed to wipe my face like a
gentleman is it the trash if I spit into
those napkins and put them back while
I'm waiting for my spicy chicken
sandwich yeah it is man but good for you
shout out to the spicy chickens it's
probably the best thing it's probably
the best thing they got it might be one
of the top sandwiches in the fast food
market what's your go-to fast food if
you're dabbling if I'm down we'll keep
it pretty tight but what is the Wendy's
Wendy's Wendy's is [ __ ] awesome do
you have that when your Wendy's up there
yeah Wendy's up there all right yeah I
made the trip Dave Thomas went
everywhere
canoe right into Canada talk about an
international businessman not Dave
Thomas was all over the map just walked
into Canada what do you eat here hello
other country yeah talking slow my uh my
an ex-girlfriend of mine worked at
Wendy's
when we were in high school and uh a
real power couple huh
Adidas and Wendy's all the nuggets and
laces you need
ankle socks and baked potatoes coming
out of your ears oh man she was that she
worked there right and she got uh so the
spicy chicken sandwich is one thing but
you know the the the the the cheese they
have for the baked potatoes oh yeah okay
so she'd get a little cup of the cheese
you put that on the spicy chicken
sandwich that's all right it's it's it's
it's a gourmet meal that's pretty good
it's a party that was the first time I
had cheese fries was at a Wendy's and
they didn't have on the menu but
somebody who's the chef
he put a little tasting menu together
for me and the boys he walked in there
like Foley's here I'll take care
everybody sits down like it is a
restaurant puts a bib on sits in the
back uh later yeah later coming anybody
because when I was working for James
Beard at the time no they they give him
his own table like in Goodfellas yeah
they walk it through a lamp
Thomas lamp the eyes light up the guy's
in the back I'm gonna go get the nuggets
the Nuggets
there's something close to the band huh
the band is two old men fighting over
coffees
free time you two every time the one
night Dave Thomas Center for two
frosties
Kennedy
I didn't think it was strange a kid this
young with Connections in the fast food
industry like that
it all seemed normal
what are you gonna do again I've been
eating
see this right here honey it's called a
Whopper Junior not even out yet I'm a
union delegate
let's go that's all right man any whole
time that's an all-time ayg reference as
I was saying fat fellas
I gotta worry about my fries getting
cold in the drive-through for this
[Laughter]
I didn't know what we were gonna do
see wapas all right
I was in the middle of my cheese fries
story all my life I wanted to work at
Wendy's anyway they're gonna have cheese
fries
ever since I was a kid I wanted to eat
flame broiled
I showed to my parents house dressed
like Ronald McDonald look at my shoes ma
where did you get these red ones
you look like a clown I'm blowing up an
Arby's truck listen
they didn't have cheese fries there at
the time all right
as I was saying
and my buddy's mom was like what you do
is you get a sign you ask for a side of
cheese and you dip your fries in it it
seems like a real classy
was that Beth you sneak in your own
cheese whiz that was it for me dude I
never I never realized you could you
could manipulate the market like that
yeah that cheese is a party it's cheese
whiz yeah and we're filling trash you
know they're just a lot of the people
that working money they're just kids man
you push them a little bit you look them
right in the ice you go hey man no
[ __ ] around give me the goddamn
cheese we're gonna give it to you oh
yeah yeah cheese
the frosties are great Wendy's is great
what do you say it's a good time uh I
don't I've never was ever a real I like
them all I was never really huge uh uh
I didn't have an alliance to one or the
other uh I like them all as an adult
though picking now because as a kid yeah
you go to anything yeah Mickey D's yeah
it tends to be a Mickey Mouse just
because it is the most there and it's
like it's you you know yeah it would be
the one I probably frequent the most is
Mickey D's all right now I love
Chick-fil-A it's it's Chick-fil-A I've
never had Chick-fil-A whoa yeah I know I
I got at some point in time I gotta I'm
sure that maybe there's probably there's
got to be somewhere in Canada that has
it I'm assuming maybe an Alberta or a
New York City baby oh I know okay go to
one here
at home like I don't think uh there
might there might be one somewhere in
Canada I don't know but anyways you got
the Hortons up there and W2 that might
be the one I love those here there
wasn't that many but there was one in my
Mall yeah they tried those but they took
long hot dogs
what the [ __ ] are we doing here and it
was never in the food court it was
always like next to Payless shoes or
whatever yeah but they also tried to
combine them with something it was like
a w and like Staples or something weird
like that it was like a weird crossover
well yeah Times Square there's a Tim
Hortons and Pizza Hut combo and you hate
that [ __ ] eat some coffee in this on the
same side of the counter they do that
with Taco Bell and Pizza Hut they do
that the biggest one is Baskin Robbins
and [ __ ] Dunkin Donuts I've said it
many times knocked that [ __ ] off that's
[ __ ] blasphemy yeah you can open up
two stores because the guys over the
overhead because it's double the leases
it's double the construction yeah but
there's never a guy over at the [ __ ]
ice cream thing if no one's really
ordering it man let's be honest here
it's a Duncan you call them over it
gives you a [ __ ] attitude good luck
trying to taste it but you're also
probably ordering at 7am and they're
[ __ ] in the weeds dude
let me get a black coffee and a banana
split what the [ __ ] dude drop the black
coffee doesn't open until noon sounds
like a green tea and a scoop of bubble
gum huh
shout out to Bubble Gum ice cream oh
that was the best back in the day you
ever had that yeah probably a great time
no I love Bubble Gum you remember that
yeah yeah cookie dough chocolate chip
cookie those in one sure mint chocolate
chips a good time but bubble gum is a
party yeah yeah I think they stopped
doing it yeah kids were choking on me
was like seven seven [ __ ] pieces of
Bubble Guppies oh yeah yeah
um Carter what are you gonna do
something
[Laughter]
are you reading a book what the [ __ ]
well that doesn't ever accuse me of that
uh all right here let's see this one's
from jayro uh I never had one red is it
garbage if a good portion of the cups
you had growing up were the hard plastic
large Slurpee cups they use for the
movie promos I was sipping Crystal Light
out of a faded Wolverine X2 cup for like
11 years
those are the [ __ ] best cups we never
kept the movie cops we always kept
anytime we went to a sports game we kept
those though yeah the Flyers Flyers cup
full of Coca-Cola and crushed ice man we
have these huge faded flies yeah they
were never they were never of the
standard increments it was never like
eight ounce 16 ounces no they were like
43. yes yeah it was like 28 or something
like that as a kid yeah one of those and
they smelled different if if you pull
one of those if they you pull one of
those out of them they weren't supposed
to be around that long high now yeah it
was probably the micro microplastics
yeah it was like if you use them take
one home and have milk in it in the
morning then throw it out but I tell you
what man pulling that out of the [ __ ]
cabinet after it's been washed a
thousand times and smelling it it was
just oh man this is trash but sodi but
this is also what everybody's doing I
had uh my mom got me obviously I
remember Batman Forever I was just
around ask if you're at these cups yeah
I did oh I talked about this on your
very first step which I think you were
the first episode of the show well I
think Nathan was the first or second
episode of the show oh yeah I think I
vaguely remember talking but no so they
had the uh they had the [ __ ] the the
engraved ones yeah they had a riddler
Two-Face Batman and a robin we had all
of those wasn't Mickey D's doing those
yeah yeah that's what McDonald's used to
give they used to [ __ ] really put it
out I remember one of the Olympics that
gave these clear coffee cups with the
little like people doing like different
things that were so [ __ ] awesome they
used to really [ __ ] give you cool
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah no now it's just
Kinder Kinder is the only one that gives
fight videos they do give us that every
day you know that's true some guy gets
that one in Philly of that the guy and
the girl going at it or in the cheese
steak place man Google that folks oh
yeah you gotta be in your life what do
you think's going do you think that's
like a lifetime of things or like that
day two people had the worst day of
their lives and they came together
combination yeah yeah it's it's two
people that don't have a lot going on
that are like I'm having a tough day the
one at the Waffle House recently is wild
too with a little blonde headed girl
[ __ ] shakes off the [ __ ] metal
chair some girl oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah like Magneto just like and then
just starts [ __ ] throwing [ __ ]
Haymakers on this how crazy is it too
that years ago there was so little of
those type of videos that when when
those did happen those people became
famous it was national news they were on
all of the things that like you see
you're the chairwoman and they're like
and those t-shirts and now they happen
so much dime a dozen dime a dozen every
weekend if you go when it doesn't happen
you're [ __ ] pissed off yeah I was in
a Dwayne read I think in uh in [ __ ]
queens and I'm waiting there in line and
some lady just snaps starts throwing all
the the chocolate bars at the cashier
behind the counter damn I just walked
out yeah what are you gonna do I'm not
recording it I'm not standing here I'm
now I'm done I don't even know this guy
would step in in that situation
somebody's got to clean all that [ __ ] up
I hate when they do that when they trash
the place two I mean it was this lady
was losing it man just like yeah left
yeah I guess I should have done
something
you're fighting a girl on [ __ ]
YouTube two girls now like the one
behind the counter and the woman that's
throwing the [ __ ] because she kind of
started throwing it back it became a
wild thing but I mean is it garbage to
walk out of a Dwayne Reed uh cashier
fight of course it's not crazy though
you never know what pushed her to that
edge
you know she wanted to return something
and the moments like you can't return
this it was like toothpaste or something
but you can't return it's not gonna
happen yeah you know what I mean you see
basically this uh Hey defective I want
to return this Lacey you can't return
that [ __ ] you throwing Mr Biggs at her
and [ __ ] that's a Payday
stamped on her head for a week that's
disrespectful you can hit that with a
chunky
[Laughter]
stuff uh all right this one's from Jane
ten dollar homie never had one red is I
would love your take on this because
you're a very particular guy is it
garbage to take a picture or video of
your meal at a high-end restaurant
dude you're doing it all the [ __ ]
time now by the way me yes sure and not
even high-end restaurants I think we're
[ __ ] eating at uh whatever every
night but where did I love that you
couldn't think of a high-end restaurant
I don't know the Dunkin Donuts on Fifth
you did it I did it at lunch huh I did
it at lunch where did we go oh okay we
have a steakhouse yeah all right I did
it because my wife was like what are you
doing I'm like I'm going to lunch with
Foley and the the fact that that was
unexpected that we went and got steaks
for lunch okay and she was like what are
you where are you going and I sent her a
picture of the state all right I'm not
posted no no never that's the question
right is it no it just says he's been
doing it a lot though I didn't do it you
got mad at them you got mad at new guy
Luke at the Christmas dinner because he
had the Flash oh yeah right don't take
your gripes with other other people and
throw them on me two seconds ago I was
like I wonder what happens what happens
in somebody's day when they come
together and actually fight and I almost
lost full breakdown you guys pulling
each other's hair throwing [ __ ] I
happen to have a pocket full of candy
bars
I just so happen to have one you would
happen to have a pocket full of fruit
I'll give you that other pocket has that
cheese in it
uh I don't I don't know if you're not
posting it then I don't know whatever
man you don't go to dinner all the time
let's say you get a you get out there
you get a [ __ ] 100 steak you want to
show somebody
he's got X-Men cups at home for [ __ ]
sake take a picture
in your life I got it and I would I I
say it's become so [ __ ] normal now
yeah and the food gets dropped people
take pictures of it they send it if
they're even if they want to post it
whatever I I don't I don't but the thing
is no one ever looks at it like think of
all the photos that were like now that
we all have [ __ ] cameras in our
pocket all the photos that we take you
never [ __ ] look at them yeah you're
not going back never no but that's what
I'm saying the only use that when I ever
do it is just my wife's like let me see
what that restaurant has okay that's
that's the only I'm not like putting in
my phone of like well I'm gonna save
this for later it's taken in the text
app of like boom this is the I posted
this is the pizza I posted on my
Instagram story but that's to continue
my Narrative of Rags to Riches has
anybody ever showed you one that's the
real trashy man like look at the steak I
ate yeah yeah we went to so and so last
night look look at how good it was no
that's crazy
[Applause]
show your pictures sucks trying to show
anybody anything on your phone never
works out oh [ __ ] wait a whole second
one second what was the date when did we
go to Turks and Caicos you're like just
[ __ ] yeah but you don't like that
because you got to tuck your boner into
your waistband let me cheat out let me
see that T-Bone steak start swiping
right
dessert too huh
yeah I'm a fat piece of [ __ ] hey no
you're not
I do I think the flash is put on VR
glasses
The Flash is a tough look The Flash is a
tough look that's whatever yeah but if
you're not like if you just do it subtly
and yeah you know I don't know but
everybody's phone is tough
yeah there's really no reason to do it
nobody cares but I don't think I'm not
against it man you're going out if I
ever went to an Outback I'd probably
take a picture of the blooming onion
just because I never I've never been
there never had one really yeah I know
what we're doing I can't have it now
don't look at me it could be your
calories for the day if you wanted to be
it could be your calories for the week
probably see what the calorie count on
an old blooming onion gotta be 1500 easy
way more easy peasy for sure they got me
at three right now three thousand yeah I
Don't Go Near it though who's they the
government the CDC
if you're not gonna wear a mask at least
eat less than 3 000 calories young man I
don't think you understand what we're
dealing with here
900 900 calories yeah but 1500
milligrams of salt that's crazy 1500
milligrams what's this
what's the daily thing you're supposed
to have a salt not that no definitely
not 1500 but I mean that's a lot is it
bad that anytime I hear you're gonna do
a whole blooming onion 2300
and that's fish so that's more than half
of your daily salt intake yeah so you
just eat that you have two bananas you
go to bed there you go it's your whole
it's your Friday
it's not a bad Friday night it's a
pretty terrible Friday you're gonna feel
[ __ ] miserable oh dude I thought that
was that thing was gonna be way weird
because that's like a shareable
sure order right yeah yeah never had one
I never had one either never been in an
Outback
um all right let's see here let's do
another Canadian kid this is Noah new
14.50 homie Canadian Cup thank you
fellas never have one red is it garbage
if your only source of income in the
last few months comes from Fantasy
Football Championship
just won 450 the other day see this
guy's from Nova Scotia that kid's a
winner I don't care who you are buddy
don't walk away from the table on a
heater double down let's go you imagine
having a whole life of only making money
on [ __ ] fantasy sports once a year
gotta break it off and chop it up over
the years just all year being like look
I ain't got it right now but I'm telling
you in eight months
yeah it's April you hit me with this now
[Laughter]
pay your rent all at the end of January
we got to do something about this
concussion protocol they're gonna take
my house
foreign
I thought that was something that you
and your buddies got together and did
it's gambling uh it's gambling uh yeah
it's for sure gambling and a lot of
times they have like a punishment if
whoever the lowest is you pull your cash
together it's like a hundred dollar
buy-in ah okay throughout the whole
season gotcha okay that's also like hey
whoever comes in last has to do the
sights do it now too like the DraftKings
and all that stuff yeah I mean they have
like
they have like crazy suicide pool they
have like uh you can do anything on
those sites that's what I'm talking
everything shout out to them which I
think we're a
draft that's why I said it yeah
DraftKings company not the other guy
promo code I wish people said where they
were from in Canada I'm just very
interested I know it's a huge country
for God's sake it is it's quite enormous
have you been all over town up there
been every single no Providence what are
they Province yeah Province I've been to
Providence I've been to I've been to
yeah I haven't been in one of the uh two
of the territories I've been to one of
the territories in the other Province
things that sound like the [ __ ] 18.
what's crazy about Canada is that most
of the population lives on this little
band right above the United States yeah
the middle is kind of because what's the
what's what's the big Zone called
uh Canada no North I was gonna say north
of that band is called it has a name oh
it's like the Canadian wall or something
something like that I I honestly don't
know but I do know that most of the the
border is where the the highest
concentration of the population is like
they said most Canadians live in that
dip that goes into they live more south
than certain people in like North Dakota
and stuff like that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and Nova scotia's not near that
border at all the way up it's so it's
over it's off to the it's off to the
side that's the water but it's under
it's under some of America like I think
Maine is higher than it may be and uh
something else but anyways we're not
we're not near that that border but yeah
the Toronto stuff all that kind of thing
the population is uh and who knows what
that is you know is that a lot of
Canadians looking over being like what's
going on it's the water it's all the
Lakes up there yeah are you close to uh
Skull Island or wherever the treasure is
not close to it but yeah every once in a
while somebody asks me about this wait
hold on
ghost Island Skull Island the The Legend
of Pirates of the Caribbean no
Jack SP yeah I know exactly what you're
talking about though because I get asked
this all the time people go is there
gold there black beard no who was it I
I'm a pirates man they went there no
there's a lot uh Oak Island Oak Island
yeah Treasure of Oak Island buddy it's
these two guys that blow millions of
dollars a year looking for treasure on
an island it's a good time really
apparently pirate history or something
Pirates went there and uh dropped off
some gold but they made my mom and my
dad they took off and uh yeah I don't
know if there's gold there or not I have
no idea but no I don't think I'm not
like near near Oak Island but it's Nova
Scotia so near it near ish gotcha never
like oh I was never on Oak Island I
didn't have a backhoe digging into this
let's head up get a couple of pickaxes
some shovels kick those guys they spend
millions of dollars they still haven't
found nothing yet how big is the eye
well it is kind of it's pretty big and
it's kind of crazy because they keep
finding different pieces of wood and
metal or Stones just bulldoze the whole
thing
you can't because it's a uh protected
like Federal whatever so they have to
like but they keep finding wood buried
down like you know 500 feet that they're
like this is from like this is like
man-made or whatever from the 30 carbon
dated to like the 1300s they're they're
looking for Captain kid's treasure which
is like it's just a bunch of tricycles
and slingshots
yoga machine that's a bunch of old
Playboys
from the 1300s yikes hilarious a woman
doing this with her dress nothing at all
cool
Captain kid is a great name that's a
good one though for a pirate Captain all
those pirate names a little kid in the
giant Captain's code
yeah fake my ship
I'll take my chocolate milk on my
quarters
that's my pleasure really I have a tummy
ache that's good uh all right let's run
through two or three more now we gotta
get out of here
um this one's from Cody ten dollar kind
of sore here is a garbage growing up is
a little fat kid you believed your mom
when she said you had to wear husky
clothes because you had beautiful blue
eyes and were very strong
because you got that long hair
now Patty never minced any any words I
knew exactly why I was wearing the tough
skins and the Huskies but I want to give
it a little [ __ ] husky did make it seem
a little as a fat at least I believed as
a fat 11 year old or whatever eight
nine-year-old you felt a little more
manly it was a little more like work
clothes I was like ah I'm a huss I'm
more mature I'm on my way to the dock
right now yeah I knew I was a fat piece
of [ __ ] but I'm gonna say I was gonna
say you poor bastard no no no I knew
exactly why I was in it because I kept
ripping [ __ ] regular Oshkosh
it was a nice turtle is it garbage to be
told that you're wearing them because
that's more I I think that's just a nice
mom I think that's you know not trying
to hurt her son's feelings yeah you
don't want to put your shirt on your kid
on the line dude that had to be a rough
realization when he found that it wasn't
because he had blue eyes his eyes are
green my mom said my grandparents from
Alaska
that's a tough luck man
um all right this one's for Miles they
were tough to break into those Huskies
this is
yeah I thought husky husky would turn
just a term no they had husky husky
sizes for little fat kids and they had
tough skin I had Tufts I had Huskies
husky sizes but like you would go to
like a JC Penney's and it would be like
the Huskies you would go husky was a
brand or a section I forget I think it
was a section
tough skin was uh so it was like cribs
yeah adults Huskies was perfect there
was a section called Huskies an area I
swear I forgot I thought that was a
brand no I remember yeah that could have
just been enough the brand uh I think it
was called fat little bastard
a fat piece of [ __ ] it's a clothing line
it is a clothing sold at Kohl's in
Walmart
yeah yeah still oh yeah no such I
thought it was a term I didn't know
there was a thing okay what about tough
skin is that a brand too uh no I think
you should talk to your dermatologist
I've been moisturized
you got snake foot
steak foot Tuscan
uh tough skin also it's a Sears brand oh
and at Walmart
hmm there you go thank God for Walmart
Sears is toast do you want to get
yourself
I used to love a Sears I used to love a
Sears too seriously no windows Casino
operation yeah yeah
no no show girls walking around
Grandma's been shopping for pants for
four days in here dude I was recently in
a Boscov's two weeks ago I carumba yeah
dude that is a tough look it's all just
Vietnam Vets walking around it's a
problem they all had their hats on and I
you know I appreciate your service but
they all uh all those places they
they've moved so much merchandise out
that so many sections of it are just
empty and there's like four things it
all looks like the clearance section
yeah yeah they put up the facade when
you first walk in they hate you with the
perfume and the handbags but then you
take a little stroll down the escalator
you're like what the [ __ ] is this it's
like a CIA black site down it just
lights off in the back inside okay
alien getting cut in half
curtains just get pulled real quick what
are you doing down here they say husky
when you close them
[Laughter]
brand new special out on the YouTube
page came out tonight whenever wakes
money never weighs 40 on finance talking
billionaires talking credit scores
talking growing up without money Rich
restaurants the like Elon Musk one of
the funniest guys doing a gang Mr
McIntosh Kippy what do you got for him
guys we're going to be announcing our
tour of everything for 2023 we got a
bunch of dates lined up uh get those
tickies when they go on sale gang we
love you and we'll see you next week
peace